let me ask you about on the Republican
side Ron DeSantis
what do you think of him as a candidate
running against uh Donald Trump I think
in the couple of weeks before our our
discussion today
his campaign which hasn't even started
has sort of started to implode and this
was something that I started thinking
about in September October he really
doesn't seem ready for prime time in the
sense that just being confronted and
confronted is not even the right word
just being asked about
uh some topics he didn't really seem to
want to talk about
he responded in such a sort of
disproportionate unhinged way during his
recent trip to Asia he was asked about
why aren't you or why are you responding
but in this weird way to Trump's attacks
on you and he went into this weird
bobble head thing with a weird smile and
something came out that didn't make any
sense and he sort of got mad at the
reporter and it was just like if you
can't handle that you can't be on a
debate stage with Donald Trump and again
for all my criticisms of trump the guy
gets you on a debate stage he can make
you look pretty silly he was recently
asked about his role at Guantanamo Bay
when he was an officer in I forget which
branch of the Armed Forces and he just
sort of attacked the journalist asking
the question and it just looked very bad
and there are increasingly big
Republican donors who are not fans of
trump and were sort of hoping to put
their eggs in the Rhonda sandis basket
who are saying this guy just doesn't
have what it takes I don't think he can
do it so I don't know if DeSantis will
be able to get away once you're polling
20 something like he is and you haven't
even announced it's very attractive and
he probably to some degree is thinking
if I wait till 2028 I might not have
this opportunity again but Trump's
polling 5253 which means even if
DeSantis gets all of the current
non-trump vote he has to figure out how
to take something more for Trump from
Trump I just don't know how he does it
first of all the implosion aspect that's
that's part of the process isn't it you
kind of implode a bunch of uh a bunch of
times and then rebuild yourself and
rebuild them because the new cycle kind
of forgets it's possible the problem is
if he the first debate is in August
so that's only a few months away and the
decision is going to be have to be made
pretty soon and unless he can get a new
momentum going uh I just don't know how
he gets what he needs in order to really
have a shot so would anyone else run
against Donald Trump it's very tough
right now I mean there are other people
running there's this guy Vivek ramaswamy
who's running Nikki Haley is running her
campaign basically Dead on Arrival
um Trump actually does better in polls
the more people run when when it's just
him and DeSantis that's the best
scenario for DeSantis it's not great for
to sand this but it's it's uh certainly
better
um but I think the difficulty is this is
a question for Republicans to figure out
the people who rightly recognized in
2016 that this guy is not good for their
party
um still believe this guy's not good for
their party but many of them recognize
that most of the voters are still behind
him
you can always say it's early his
polling doesn't really mean anything
anything could happen something major
would have to happen for Trump to lose
that lead if he got more uh if he was
arrested two more times and had more
indictments and it just became like this
guy can't even campaign because he's so
busy going from court to court maybe
that would make a difference it's really
tough to imagine